[Music]
[Applause]
he's david carr the nfl network analyst
former nfl quarterback you can follow
him on twitter at d carr
eight david thanks for joining us uh
what did you think of last night's game
dan i mean it was it was what we kind of
expected but before we get to that i
just i think sometimes our birthdays
lose a little bit of magic as we get
older and i wanted to make sure that
you know paulie
just gets acknowledged for having a
birthday because i know that that is
sometimes a it can be a
source of frustration and depression
so happy birthday paulie but paula you
have something to say hold on david
pauline has something to say thanks
david you're back to being my favorite
car brother again it was derek for a
long time and you're back okay all right
all right thanks man okay i appreciate
that i hope you have a birthday buddy
but yeah when you
so you look at that game
and chris mccaffery obviously is the
center point of that offense and i was
doing our show last night with ladainian
thompson
great running back he was also the
center point of an offense and i was
talking to him as christian left that
game i said that's that's gotta be
really difficult because joe brady's
offensive system
is so geared to getting him christian in
position to make plays in the run game
in the passing game and then now he's
all of a sudden gone
you know you're gonna look like maybe
you're not really hitting your stride
against the team that you should
probably be handling so i think that was
a lot of the
offensive issues they're just trying to
make some dj more good players sam
donald i love what they're doing with
him
matt rule i've known matt rule since he
was an assistant offensive line coach
in new york and matt has touched every
base like he has his hand
in the offensive line in the defense he
knows what gives each position group
trouble and i think that's what's so
brilliant just about what they're doing
on the defensive side is they're
basically running a college scheme a
three three five i was talking to derek
about this you know this summer i was
like who's the most difficult defense
schematically he's like the panthers
they just create so many different
issues
from a schematic steam
standpoint and you watch them against
the saints last week they were in the
same blitz three plays in a row against
sean payton's offense and jameis winston
who's a veteran quarterback and they got
home every time and it's not just scheme
it's the personnel up front so when i
look at the panthers it's like
you don't really expect a lot out of
them but until you really dig into it
and you look at each position group and
how they're kind of put together and you
can't help but like get excited for that
team even without christian like he'll
come back that hamstring hopefully won't
be something that lingers all year
he'll come back in there i think they'll
be able to hold down the fort i just
like what they do schematic they like
how they're put together i'm really
happy for sam i think he's a he's a good
player and they're doing what he does
well you watch him on the run and making
plays after the fact that's almost when
he's at his best so
i'm excited to watch them play but i
wonder what they do with christian
mccaffrey as we move forward he got paid
you want to use him but then you also
know that there's this fine line of how
much we use him are we over using him
you almost have to manage somebody that
is one of your highest paid players
yeah i agree and it is a situation where
in christian's case he's not gonna come
out he i mean i remember him a couple
years ago saying that he wanted to be in
on every snap on offense and it's like
man i know that you love the game but
dude you're not gonna make it and i even
heard him talking
in our pregame
about how he has to take less hits
he has to find a way to avoid contact a
little bit so as you start to get a
little bit older you understand that
yeah i do have to kind of conserve the
the body and you hope that a coaching
staff would do that for you so
i don't know i don't know what the
answer is there i know that you just
look at the running back position
and these guys are just they just
they're overworked and you get a guy
like le'veon bell who's basically just
standing on the sideline for a team
right now who was probably one of the
best running backs two three years ago
you can go through the list you can todd
gurley zeke elliott is getting his role
diminished in dallas it's just the shelf
life just isn't very long so what do you
do you know do you just go full out let
me give you everything i got
you know if i if i kind of
you know put yourself on a pitch count
or you let the team do it do you get
maybe another year out of it you know
i'm almost to the point where it's like
let's just max out his ability let's see
what he can do and
and then when it's over it's over but
it's a rough world for running backs but
man that's just kind of the world we
live in
yeah but that's what i would do david if
i'm taking a running back in the first
round first of all i wouldn't but if i
did take one i'm gonna use him as much
as i possibly can and then i'll find
another running back it i i can find
running backs and um
i just i don't we're in the same boat on
that one i tell everybody everybody i'm
like i would never pay a running back
why would you pay running back just go
get another one i mean there's look at
what look what the ravens are doing i
mean they have great running backs
nothing wrong with their all those guys
got hurt oh the raven season's over
let's beat the chiefs
and they're running the football i mean
i know lamar was a big part of that but
dude you can find anybody to run the
ball
you really can
i did think of you last night as i'm
watching davis mills a rookie starting
for the texans and uh he was going for
your record of i think you were sacked
six times in your in your debut did that
bring back
painful memories for you
yeah it did the same jerseys i mean same
stadium different name but it's like
and you just knew schematically that
kind of we talked about earlier they
were going to bring a ton of different
looks and he just hoped that the
coaching staff would just give him some
answers and and to their credit early on
like in the first two series
they were trying to get the ball out of
his hand as fast as possible and they
realized they weren't even get a first
down i mean i think i looked up at one
point and i think they had 14 plays and
the panthers had 14 first downs so it's
like okay now we got to kind of try to
do something here so let's uh let's
maybe step on the gas but it's it's not
a great situation for davis i actually
like davis out of out of school and i
think i think that if you had to know
you stayed another year he made a first
round pick but
you know he's he's just in a tough
situation it's not going to be good
yeah and and i don't know what goes
through your mind because here you are
making your nfl debut and you got your
friends and family and everybody's
watching and then you go out there and
you're like
oh my god
you know you have to know though like
i mean i guess i guess i i didn't
because we beat the cowboys the first
game and we're like oh this is easy and
we go to san diego play the chargers and
junior sales in the a gap hits me a
hundred times
and i'm like oh maybe it's not so easy
like you think you would know but like
you have to kind of i'm i had 20 years
so i have that luxury
who was the guy though that you just
when you saw him you knew this this
isn't going to work out well for me
it was that it well okay i take it back
it was junior stay out in that game but
fortunately we didn't play them as much
after that
but really for me it was dwight freeny
because we had we just had i mean
honestly we i can say this now we had no
shot of beating those guys when we were
when when the colts were rolling we
would go to indy
and i mean my dad came to a game and he
said that's the last road game i'm ever
going here i'm like yeah why would you
pick indianapolis to come to like
the worst possible scenarios like
they're going to be up 21 nothing it's
literally going to be blitz fest i
remember the very first play of the game
we played indy they're already up seven
nothing of course we get we get the ball
i i snapped the ball
my left tackle does not even get out of
his stance you can probably go on
youtube and find this he doesn't even
move out of the stance dwight friend
hits me in the back head ball flies out
fumble 14 nothing i mean it's just like
we didn't have a chance to play those
guys dwight franny is the bane of my
existence for a long time
[Laughter]
uh
how do how often do you think each week
you have to def or you feel like you
need to defend your brother
um with
i mean maybe not anymore but
was it a weekly process a daily process
where you had this sort of do i still or
did you stick up for your brother
yeah dude you know i was like to him i
would never stick up to him i'm always
kind of like going to be hard on him and
whatnot but it's like that's my job as a
big brother but like
up until this year
it really was uh to the point of like
how i mean how
i don't know how other how else to say
this like just look at the numbers look
what he does
the problem was their defense was
terrible that's just what it was like so
they would never get
enough possessions to be able to never
get a stop in key situations they'd be
like okay we're right there and then you
know blown coverage beat kansas city
last year the first time second time
about to beat him again
blown coverage touchdown travis kelsey
wide open like what's happening so this
year we get to this
situation we're in now and now all of a
sudden
he's a good player you know um and
people are trying to figure out
what happened between 2016 and right now
i'm like well nothing he's just been
steadily getting better you just look at
the numbers look at him and john's
system they've been on the rise but
you know their defense was ranked 30th
or whatever they were last year so just
just be you know gruden talked about
this i was out there for training camp
and we were just kind of he's like dave
all we have to do is he just give me of
course he says me give me two more
possessions
you know with the football
and we'll we'll be fine and i'm like i
guess if you look big picture that's
probably right then you look at what
they did against the ravens
strip sack in overtime one extra
possession touchdown steelers same thing
one extra possession big play henry
ruggs touched down off the fumble so
you're like okay i guess it makes sense
and if you look over the
the big picture throughout the entire
season that's going to add you know i
mean how many wins is that going to add
i guess we'll find out at the end but
offensively they've always been
they've been there like since darren
waller has been there and gruden and
those guys and they have that type of
big time match up guy
all these other guys hunter renfroe
starting to step up rugs is making more
plays down the field you know brian
edwards you know they they're going to
be fine on offense it's it's really been
defense and max crosby has played
fantastic yannick way another guy
battled through a hamstring injury to
play against
you know
the steelers this last week put some
pressure on the quarterback back ends
making some plays casey hayward hasn't
even given up a completed pass on him
this year so i mean
what else do you want they got it they
got a chance now
okay i want you to play the role of tom
brady
and you're you're facing this rams
defense
what are you gonna what are you gonna
try to take advantage of
so i went back and watched this
game from them last last year week 11
yesterday
just to kind of refresh my memory on
what happened how they you know what
went wrong for the bucks
and it was really as easy as aaron
donald
they they were not able to consistently
run the football
and put enough pressure on them to
not just play the pass and and aaron and
those guys just pushed the pocket back
and brady's lap and he made a couple bad
throws and that was the difference i
mean jared got through the ball
50-something times in that game matt
stafford is clearly capable of doing the
same thing cooper cup had a huge day
last year he's going to have another one
in la i i don't think that there's going
to be anything different from a ram
standpoint what they want to do they
pretty much did what they wanted to
they didn't even really try to run the
football because even when you do play
tampa bay a lot of people just don't
even attempt it because
because they're just solid up front so
fast and physical very gap sound
difficult but you can spread them out
and throw the ball i think matt stafford
can't do that but from a buccaneer
standpoint
i really think that they have to try to
do some things to slow him down whether
it be like these little trap passes you
know not necessarily rpos but some type
of play action some type of make it look
like run because if you just drop back
aaron donald i don't care how good your
offense line is he's gonna push back
on that and make it difficult because
brady let's i mean if he's
at this point if he does have a weakness
he's he's going to be seven yards deep
behind the center i mean that's just it
at the end of the day and and good
defenses know that and they can they can
push the pocket there and you know he's
not going to be outside the pocket do
anything fancy so
i think that's really what it comes down
to in this game
is trying to slow down that that push by
aaron donald on the inside really not
the outside guys brady's
stepped up and used pocket presents
forever to get away from those guys but
it's the inside push that created some
bad throws i think it comes down to that
great to talk to you as always david
have a great weekend thanks for joining
us
youtube buddy all right man have a good
day that's david carr nfl network
analyst some good stuff there